[Music]
Will Smith and Mark Antony performed
their track esta Neko at last night's
Latin Grammys and moments after they
stepped off that stage will bass book
exclusively to our Kevin Frazier oh it
is good to know two old guys still have
Flair that was judge the sword how did
it feel to perform this song live for
the first time I love that that's
beautiful man you can see the perfect
achi take a shower come out dress up a
little bit
what's it like being with these two
legends moines plus lambda1 romantically
animal company la mera Danny no Will
Smith content of Ali you're right no
look you're right you're right I heard
say will you know I got your number boy
I can't believe you called me out like
that I was just like you do the head
down yes so that totally just happened
but oh I got mine will spoke to et for
the first time about his role as the
genie in the live-action film Aladdin I
was terrified doing the genie you know
after Robin Williams you know and but
you know I found a lane that that you
know pays Beach but it's my own thing
you know so it's I think this people are
gonna love it and then we'll finally set
things right
you're very handsome tonight do you like
this you like this tell the world you
love to share you look handsome I think
you like the circuit don't normally like
him I'm gonna keep it real I usually
don't like the stuff you wear but
tonight you look really really handsome
you know you got your little black
George Clooney going tonight yeah I'm a
quad and do it imma go out and do it
right now and it's Clooney so much fun
hanging out with those two and by the
way mark and will worldwide together
have sold more than 30 million albums
that is the definition of superstars
[Music]